in terms of early on in my professional
journey what would i have done
differently
thinking long term is very hard for
young people
and so there's a balance there you want
to have that success so you start
thinking like
i need a 10k raise i need a 5k
raise i want to have my own office i i
was obsessed with some of those kind of
things early in my career i really
wanted my own office for some reason
when i was working at sony i was like oh
i got my own office like that means
something to me
um and then looking back on it
that wasn't what was important you know
there were bigger important things
uh i think i could have taken a little
more risk i mean i was pretty
risk-taking but
even for myself i i look at everything i
do now and say
how can i take more risk what would be
even more audacious
like i've been looking at this podcast
and saying can i get it to five days a
week because we were supposed to be this
week in startups like once a week
then it was twice a week then it was
three times a week and i was like i
wonder if i could get to
dally that would be interesting i don't
know if we will i mean
we could do it but i don't know if i
would survive but i really am enjoying
doing it so
uh think bigger when i was on angel list
and naval showed me angel list i was
like oh that's cute like
it's sort of like my open angel form but
on a website
and he's like yeah it's going to change
everything syndicates i was like i don't
understand what's a syndicate he's like
it's an spv it's an llc like i start
glossing over us anytime i hear
legal stuff i'm just glossing over and
they said trust me it'd work
and i was like alright i'll try it so i
do a spv
special purpose vehicle llc do my first
syndicate on
angel list turns out to become my second
best investment of all time
and i was like wow this is amazing
there's like 300 people in my syndicate
in the first year
then i left angel list i wrote my book
angel and now i have over 5000 people
growing at 500 a month in the largest
syndicate of the world at
thesyndicate.com
i should have left angel list after the
first deal and just done it myself right
but i thought oh maybe i need to be on
this platform maybe i need the help of
the support
and i think just continuing to be more
audacious
and to swing and go you know i
you have to assume and believe that you
can get it done
that's another way of kind of looking at
it and if you just assume
well somebody's got to figure this out
why not me somebody's got to be the
world's best angel investor somebody's
got to have the
you know joe rogan didn't wake up one
day and be like i'm the best comedian
ever
it was like i host a game show that's
makes
people eat worms or something i mean
what was that called fear factor
i mean but he followed his passion and
for some reason he became the number one
podcaster in the world because he liked
having these long conversations he
clearly studied howard stern
and thought you know there's something
there and he followed his his
his passion and he went big he went
daily that's another thing he did like
so it was
putting your two questions together the
fact that he went daily he became a
habit for people